françois hollande chef de chantier d'un
jour l'ancien président de la république
et deux passages en touraine aujourd'hui
à cause des passoires thermiques avec
les compagnons bâtisseurs l'association
lauréate de sa fondation qui a touché
150 mille euros dead ses bénévoles et
salariés donnent un coup de main pour
rénover l'habitat des personnes
défavorisées
exemple à nazelles négron avec romain
débile
christelle a appris vendredi la visite
de françois hollande dans sa maison
cette habitante de nazelles négron a
posé sa journée pour accueillir l'ancien
président de la république et demandé à
ses enfants de ranger leur chambre
je n'y croyais pas du tout je pensais
qu'à la dernière minute on peut dire eh
ben non en fait ça nul et il ne peut pas
venir la colline l'organisation c'est
pas possible
11h du matin celui qui préside depuis
2010 est la fondation la france s'engage
franchi le pas de porte
bonjour alors j'ai entendu parler de
vous qui m'a aidé sont inouïes bien or
bien
à la réunion ce matin d une des familles
qui avaient reçu vide comme castrés
station animée
laurent était parfait est intervenu au
bon moment la fondation a soutenu
l'association les compagnons bâtisseurs
qui ont développé un projet de chantier
participatif chez christelle ils sont
intervenus dans la salle de bain le
principe c'est que je ne viens pas là
pour faire les travaux de monsieur
madame je viens ici pour faire faire les
travaux à la famille et la famille au
sens large les amis et les voisins ceux
qui veulent aider donc l'idée c'est de
faire des chantiers participatifs
encadré par un professionnel du bâtiment
en 2021 la france s'engage soutiendra
encore une quinzaine de projets sociaux
et solidaire la crise sanitaire a
apporté de nouveaux critères
parmi les conditions que nous avons
posées pour tenir compte de la crise
sanitaire
il ya la lutte contre l' isolement parce
qu'on s'est aperçu que coville avait
attribué à isoler les personnes donc il
faut essayer de trouver des associations
qui vont justement permettre qu' il y
ait une solidarité et une proximité un
travail en commun
la fondation reçoit chaque année 500
projets a sélectionné le concours est
ouvert jusqu'au 23 février